now on to our top story here at 11 the
cobit 19 vaccine now available for
nevada in 70 and older
but there's still some confusion about
where to go to sign up brian
yeah there are different forms that are
online so which ones do you fill out
orkel mana has those answers everybody
is anxious
claire allen is ready to put this
pandemic behind her she turns 80 years
old later this month
and is thrilled she can now get the
covet 19 vaccine i'm looking forward to
it
i think that we need to be courageous
and understand we help
each other but with several online forms
now posted scheduling an appointment is
overwhelming
it's very confusing so here's what you
need to know if you're in nevada in age
70 or older
or a frontline essential worker you can
sign up for a covet 19 vaccine
clark county and the southern nevada
health district say you should go to the
health district's website and choose
from one of these options
like many allen saw this error message
officials are urging patients as spots
fill up
saying more dates will become available
you have to go with the flow one day at
a time
the city of north las vegas posted this
special form for its residents 70 and
older
filling it out puts you in the system
and then someone will contact you to
officially schedule a vaccination
the state also created a vaccine
interest form for all nevadans to fill
out you're encouraged to do so but the
county spokesperson tells me
it's more of a gauge to see who wants it
and does not actually schedule an
appointment
some like 89 year old eddie zierod are
ok with waiting
i think everybody is doing pretty much
the best they can do under the
circumstances right now all agree
access to the vaccine is good news we
can
all get better orco mana 8 news now
again this is a really big step in the
vaccination
process officials are asking for your
patience
we have more information links to those
online forms that you'll need to fill
out
all on our website eightnewsnow.com